c'est en france que car les plus
démentes leader indépendantiste catalan
exilé en belgique a choisi de tenir son
premier meeting au moins 68 personnes
sont attendues un événement qui se
déroulera au parc des expositions de
perpignan une provocation dont manuel
valls ancien candidat à la mairie de
barcelone qui dénonce un manque de
respect pour un pays voisin
des élus de tous bords vont recevoir en
grande pompe à perpignan un dirigeant
politique qui a fui l'espagne et qui est
poursuivi par la justice d'un état de
droit
cet indépendantiste qui n'a rien d'un
progressiste affirme venir en catalogne
nord et non pas en france l'ex-premier
ministre français y voient une
provocation et soutient tous les
identités locales que les inspirations
d'autonomie sont contraires aux valeurs
européennes les identités et les
différentes formes de séparatisme sont
opposés au principe républicain et
européens
cette provocation ne peut se dérouler
sans une réaction politique et de
principe des autorités françaises et des
formations politiques républicaines un
avis également partagé par des
politiques français qui dénonce le
comportement de l'état
al'approche des élections municipales
manuel valls a raison de nous alerter
les élus français qui envisagent de
recevoir puis-je de monte à perpignan on
double mentor ils défient les autorités
légales et légitimes de l'espagne et ils
méconnaissent aussi l'indivisibilité de
notre république française
c'est évident qu'il ya un soupçon de
récupération c'est un objet politique
externe qui vient dans cette campagne
la question que je me pose c'est
pourquoi quinze jours avant le premier
tour des municipales
ça vient perturber la campagne
électorale un meeting qui fait polémique
pour carlès plus de monde qui seront
donc en catalogne
deux ans et demi après avoir quitté
précipitamment espagne où il est
toujours visé par un mandat d'arrêt
[Musique]